a dos semanas de jurar el cargo gustavo
petro cumple con una de las promesas que
hizo en campaña electoral el mandatario
colombiano suspendió las órdenes de
captura y de extradición de los
negociadores del ejército de liberación
nacional que se encuentran en cuba
dejando claro su intención de avanzar en
un proceso de paz con esa guerrilla y
poner fin a seis décadas de
levantamiento armado
suspender órdenes de captura a esos
negociadores
para intentar construir el camino ojalá
rápido y expedito en donde esta
organización
deje de ser una guerrilla insurgente en
colombia expertos creen que la decisión
del presidente petro es clave para
alcanzar la paz como lo explicó a france
24 luis eduardo celis son pasos
procedentes hacia restablecer una
negociación es el camino correcto de
crear las condiciones para ese
entendimiento recordar que el gobierno
anterior colocó nuevamente las órdenes
de captura
solicitudes de extradición y fue todo un
desastre ese es a esa política entonces
es una muy buena noticia para
restablecer esa negocio tan importante
para la paz de colombia la delegación de
paz en cuba está conformada por 10
integrantes entre ellos dos altos mandos
del grupo armado la ruptura de las
negociaciones sucedió a raíz de un
ataque con coche-bomba contra una
escuela de policía que dejó al menos 22
muertos a principios de 2019 ahora el
grupo guerrillero en la habana debe
establecer contacto con sus similares en
colombia para consultar los pasos a
seguir en la reapertura del proceso